en el vídeo pasado encontramos el valor
actual de estas tres formas de pago si
tenemos una tasa del 5% sin riesgo y si
nuestros pagos son completamente sin
riesgo ahora en lugar de que yo te pague
a ti
podemos ver este ejercicio como un
programa del gobierno en el que te
pregunta cuál de estas opciones
prefieres y vamos a usar la misma tasa
de interés que el gobierno te pagaría si
lo hubieras prestado tu dinero y esta es
justo la tasa de tesorería en el vídeo
pasado suponemos que esta es una tasa
del 5% si viste el primer vídeo del
valor actual seguro te acordarás de que
ir aumentando hacia adelante es lo mismo
que ir descontando hacia atrás si
quieres saber cuánto valen 100 pesos
dentro de un año
tienes que multiplicarlo por uno más la
tasa de interés lo cual es igual a
multiplicarlo por 1.05 si tu tasa de
interés es del 5%
si yo más los 110 pesos y quiere saber
cuánto valen un año antes pues lo
divides entre 1.05 es la misma operación
si vas hacia delante múltiple
si vas hacia atrás divides en el vídeo
pasado obtuvimos que el valor actual
deja mención otro color y voy a
introducir mi notación mano al valor
actual suponiendo que la tasa de interés
es del 5% sin importar cuánto tiempo
prestes tu dinero que tan lejos de
dentro dinero en el tiempo vas a ver a
qué me refiero cuando cambie esta
suposición pero bueno si suponemos que
la tasa de interés sin riesgo es de 5%
entonces el valor actual de 100 pesos
pues ya sabemos que 100 pesos pero el
valor actual de 110 pesos en dos años es
110 entre 1.05 al cuadrado
5% del primer año y 5% del segundo año
y eso obtuvimos que era igual a 99
puntos 77 pesos se nos está acabando el
espacio después en la opción número 3
para calcular el valor actual lo
dividimos no tomamos el valor actual de
20 pesos ahorita que son 20 pesos más 50
pesos dentro de un año o sea 50 entre
1.0 5 más 35 pesos dividido entre 1.0 5
al cuadrado por los 2 años
y eso obtuvimos quedan 99 puntos 36 eso
es lo que valen para ti estos pagos si
supones que estos pagos son
completamente fuera de riesgo con un 5
por ciento de tasa de interés y un
riesgo basándonos en estos cálculos la
opción número 1 era la mejor la segunda
mejor opción era la 2 y la última era la
3 ahora qué pasa y tal vez quieras
ponerle pausa y pensarlo muy bien qué
pasa si no supongo que hay un 5 por
ciento de tasa de interés qué pasa si
supongo que hay un interés del 2% y sin
riesgo bueno esta es mi notación cuál es
el valor actual de estas cosas si
suponemos que hay una tasa del 2% pues
de los 100 pesos nos lo van a dar hoy
por lo cual tienen un valor actual de
100 pesos de hecho lo podemos ver como
100 pesos divididos entre 1.02 elevadas
a la potencia cero pero eso nada más
dividir entre 2
entonces nos quedan los 100 pesos
y cuál es el valor actual de 110 pesos
dentro de dos años esto es muy
interesante cuando la tasa interés baja
entonces estamos dividiendo entre algo
más chico 1.02 es más chico que 1.05 al
cuadrado los dos entonces el valor
actual de este desde 110 pesos va a
subir y eso es algo que hay que tomar en
cuenta cuando veamos otras cosas
entonces bueno el valor actual de este
pago va a subir veamos así tal cual
cuánto sube 110 pesos entre un 1.02 al
cuadrado muy bien lo estamos descontando
dos veces porque son dos años y
obtenemos 105 pesos con 77 centavos
72 centavos perdón y como tuve eso lo
estoy haciendo al revés aquí pero a ver
son 110 pesos divididos entre 1.0 2 al
cuadrado en nuestra intuición esto
gobierno
solo por bajar la tasa interés del 5 al
2 por ciento el valor actual de este
pago dentro de dos años o sea que está
en el año tres pero es dentro de dos
años porque estamos en el año 1 bueno
debería de llamarle el día de hoy ya
esto debería llamarle el año 1 que es
dentro de un año si el año 1 es hoy y
este debería ser el año 2 entonces este
es ahorita o sea ya el año cero este es
el año 1 y este es el año dos buenos el
valor actual de esto subió seis pesos
sólo por cambiar la tasa de interés
muy bien ahora qué pasa con la opción
número 3 en la opción número 3 los 20
pesos hoy valen 20 pesos en el día de
hoy más 50 entre 1.20 dos más 35
dividido entre 1.02 al cuadrado porque
son dos años y veamos cuánto vale
entonces 20 más 50 entre 1.0 2
las 35 / 1.02 al cuadrado
102 puntos 66 pesos entonces esto es
igual a 102 puntos 66 pesos y hay
algunas cosas muy interesantes aquí y
este es el momento para hablar de ellas
de repente bajamos la tasa de interés y
ahora la opción número 2 es la mejor
opción seguida de la opción número 3 y
al último la opción 1 y bueno la opción
número 1 era la mejor opción cuando
tenemos una tasa del 5% pero ahora con
una tasa del 2% la opción número 2 es la
mejor opción y hay otra cosa interesante
aquí la segunda opción mejoró mucho más
que la tercera el valor actual cambio de
99 puntos 74 a 105 puntos 72 casi 6
pesos y aquí en la tercera opción
aumentó aproximadamente 3 pesos ahora
por qué pasa eso pues cuando bajamos la
tasa de interés los términos a los que
les afectan más son los que más se
benefician todo este pago está a 2 años
por lo cual la tasa le afecta al
cuadrado baja le afecta con un peso de 2
años
todos estos pagos están dispersos al
ahora de los años sólo algunos los
afecta durante dos años algunos les
afecta solo un año y les va a afectar
menos y algunos no les afectan nada o
sea están justo el día de hoy entonces
en total les va a beneficiar menos bueno
los voy a dejar en este vídeo pero en el
siguiente vídeo vamos a ver qué pasa
cuando tenemos distintas tasas
dependiendo de la cantidad de años nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo